[Musik]
bitte lass mich rein wenn ich könnte ich
würde alles rückgängig machen
die ganze lügerei so viele jahre lang
es ist einfach passiert
ich komme aus duisburg mein vater
bearbeiten der stahlindustrie und ich
später auch wir sind wie so viele in den
60er jahren ins ruhrgebiet gezogen
das ist dann keine arbeiten haben aber
ich sah gut aus mit den frauen fremd ist
immer und immer wenn ich mit einer
ausgegangen war bestand sie darauf mich
einzuladen den armen arbeitslosen
burschen irgendwann
[Musik]
irgendwann habe ich das dann genutzt und
verinnerlicht meine miete zahlte ich mit
gebrauchtwagenhandel fahrräder alle
möglichen krank wenn die frauen
ermöglichten die ein schönes leben
schönes leben
das bedeutet jetzt nur noch mit ihr
zusammen zu sein und ich allein bin voll
wenn das ein traum rein